cette norme l'audience est reprise je
vous rappelle que nous jugeons
aujourd'hui patrick poivre d'arvor qui
est accusé d' exercice illégal de la
pharmacie puisqu'il en effet déclaré
qu'il était vendeur je suis vendeur je
vends des produits que les autres ont
préparé ce qui laisse sous-entendre que
l'information télévisée n'est qu'une
vulgaire potion à prendre deux soirs
avant ou après le dîner
nous allons d'ailleurs connaître les
griefs de la société française votre
égard monsieur poivre d'arvor puisque va
se lever maintenant non pas un nouveau
soleil
mais le procureur général de la
république des proches française
[Musique]
thank you just
françaises français belges belle mon
président pour de rire
monsieur l'avocat du barreau de mes deux
chaises coucher pro gay mesdames et
messieurs les jurés public chéri mon
amour ah le beau jeune homme que voilà
ah qu'il est beau aquila la jambe et
lancer la main fine et les dents longues
adieu tripote qu'elle et moi comme mon
regard croise tient pas ce mois le
poivre d'abord comment regard croise le
tient je reviendrai à douter de ma
virilité et a regretté de ne point être
avocat pour pouvoir [ __ ] moi aussi
n'est-ce point ta signe du destin
mesdames et messieurs les jurés que la
présence parmi nous au premier jour de
l'automne d'un vrai romantique
à l'automne les
les sanglots longs des violons de
l'automne verse mon coeur d'une longueur
comme qui dirait monotone le sont-ils
point sublime sévère douloureux que lens
et hier soir vers la nuit embrasé la
voix désolé de paul verlaine ou pop club
de rimbaud en recul faudra-t-il que
j'aie le coeur aussi sec que le gosier
d'un bébé du sahel monsieur le président
pour réclamer la peine maximum à
l'encontre d'un authentique vrais
nouveaux romantiques d'un homme éperdu
de l'éternel chagrin des enfants du
siècle d'un homme qui vit sa mort jour
après jour en adorant la vie d'un homme
qui valait sharp au vent mauvais
frissonnant dans l'éprouvette amertume
des sous-bois de l'automne où le loup de
vigny fini d'exhaler sont impossibles
râle d'un homme enfin déchiré par les
contradictions insupportables de sa
personnalité de demi dieux vivants
moitié chateaubriand moitié jean claude
bourret
toute mon enfance a été bercée du chant
désolé du romantisme
moi aussi parce qu'on le poivre moi
aussi j'ai appris tout enfant à
comprendre la mouvance émotionnel de
cette errance éclairé de la pensée
lyrique qui nous conduit naturellement à
laisser prévaloir le sentiment sur la
raison et l'imagination fertile sur la
froide analyse donc si vous ne suivez
pas finie connais l'histoire ben oui moi
aussi passe moi le poivre et pippa small
cell je vécus j'ai vécu cela grâce et
l'éducation romantique de mes parents
père allait les chars pouvant mauvais
frissonnant dans les couvents amertume d
herbe en friche de l'automne il était
romantique exhibitionniste au bord du
périphérique nord et est mère mère
vivait sa mort en adorant la vie
vibrante au son du cor le soir au fond
du couloir à l'été d'un petit romantique
gironnais le roi du chateaubriand pommes
vapeur et moi moi je suis leur enfant
fragile et gracieux et nous sommes des
milliers nous sommes des millions
d'enfants de l'aube qui souffrons l'âme
écorché comme lamartine le coeur ampleur
comme chopin et l'air con comme gonzague
saint brieuc terre sauvage où chante la
bise et fientes la mouette saint brieuc
où la bigoudène est de passage
puisqu'elle est le finistère et pas des
codes d'une heure faut pas chercher à me
laisser sur le géo saint brieuc dont je
me demande pourquoi je t'en parle
ah oui ça oui saint brieuc est le
berceau du romantisme
là ça sent bon et c'est là mesdames et
messieurs les jurés en vacances à saint
brieuc que j'ai découvert et aimé le
livre émouvant de file moi le sel les
enfants les enfants de l'aube
je ne vous en voudrez pas ici toutes les
ficelles d'ailleurs peut-on parler de
ficelle alors qu'il s'agit bien des
normes cordages et même temps l'amour
est présent à chaque chapitre de corde à
noeuds mais quelle chef-d'oeuvre call
chef-d'oeuvre jamais nous ne
remercierons assez patrick fait voir
aussi la moutarde cuillère pour 100
livres pour son livre dont au sujet de
son talent duquel la littérature
française elle serait pas été pareil si
qui serait pas été publiés
[Applaudissements]
les enfants de l'aube nous conte
l'histoire d'un adolescent leucémiques
qu'ils rencontrent dans un hôpital à
leucémiques une jeune anglaise
leucémiques dans un style leucémiques
également l'auteur nous conte la passion
brûlante et désespérée de ces deux êtres
fragiles mais tremblant tremblant
d'amour et qui vont vers leur destin la
main dans la main et la zigounette dans
le pilou pilou
malgré la maladie qui fait fuir leur
entourage et notamment les marchands
d'assurance vie alfred de vigny et
ginette chateaubriand nos deux héros
décident de forcer le destin et de
donner la vie à un enfant afin de mettre
toutes les chances de réussite de ce
projet insensé de leur côté il commence
par observer de papillon soit mienne dit
alfred page 36 take it off masseur is
coming
[Rires]
opta mains voila ma mère dit ginette
dans la langue de ses pairs car elle en
avait deux à ce stade du récit le
lecteur est bouleversée et ce sans
défaillir
car il en est du romantisme cuivreux
comme de la moule pro frêche quand on en
abuse ça fait mal au ventre
un mois plus tard alfred de vignettes et
ginette de chateaubriand qui était allé
voir le story pour se remonter le moral
se retrouve dans tête à tête par un doux
crépuscule de septembre au bord du lac
léman la splendeur foutrait du jour qui
se meurt sur la campagne belge et reins
le coeur de la malheureuse enfant elle
sait que ça ferait preuve elle sait que
sa fin est proche la jaille de la veille
à l'insu de son jeune amant elle a
consulté le plus grand cancérologue de
genève qui lui a dit c'est 300 francs my
darling mon pauvre amour dit elle
qu'allons nous devenir je sens la vie me
quittait doucement mais je ne veux pas
mourir que faire observons de papillons
répond-t-il passe 87 et il la prend dans
ses bras tandis que l'astre du jour se
font sur le lac endormi page 81 puis
c'est leur terrible de la ve un jour
alors qu'ils jouent tous les deux à
cache cache la jeune femme rongée par le
mâle décide de dire à son amant qu'elle
attend un enfant de lui
iam in the clock dit ed
je suis dans la peau du jeu à cache
cache pas nous en faire une
je suis dans la pendule mon dieu
un enfant qui on est absolument certaine
ma chérie oui mon amour je n'ai pu me
tromper le mois dernier j'ai pas vu
venir dit elle de plus en plus augmenté
mais ma chérie c'est merveilleux viens
m'embrasser observons de papillons à la
fin du livre le lecteur ne contient plus
ses larmes
en effet la malheureuse mère ne survivra
pas à la naissance de son enfant une
petite fille que son père appellera
grenelle en hommage à la motte piquet
grenelle
le peintre romantique du changement à
réaumur sébastopol
le livre se termine en douloureuse à peu
près aussi par cette image insoutenable
du père arpentant la plaine d'irlande
brumeuse et glacée ou se lève un pâle
soleil d'automne l'homme va briser
soutenu par sa mère et par sa soeur
comme lui vêtu de noir
soudain il s'arrête face à la lande
austère et regardant tour à tour les
deux femmes
il s'écrit observons trois papillons je
rappelle le titre
les enfants de l'aube par patrick poivre
d'arvor chez jean claude lattès 200
pages 203 pages exactement de romantisme
décapant pour le prix d'un kilo de
déboucher évier et maintenant je
rappelle le pic
[Musique]
etonnant non